[Music]  so if you're trying to avoid wool why  not make that leap say I'm never gonna  buy wool again Alysia silverstone would  rather go naked than wear wool that's  exactly you what her new PETA ad says  yep the 40 year old clueless star is  stripping down again for the  organization all in an effort to prevent  the use of wool in fashion the biggest  thing that people always say to me is  how could they just share them the Sheep  they don't don't kill the Sheep the  shearing isn't like oh let me just take  your hair off because you need to give  me your coat it's not like that it's  like on the slaughterhouse floor where  there's a conveyor belt and it's going  that fast  Alysia became a vegan back in 1998 and  took it all off for PETA the first time  back in 2007 every choice you make has  such a profound effect  you